[Music]
good evening members officers ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this meeting of the
development committee 28th of September
2023.
I will now read out the emergency
evacuation procedure
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the storeroom adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is in the island
in front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that this meeting will be
live streamed
and can I ask you please to switch off
mobiles or turn them onto silent
ly got reminded that this is an official
council meeting and the applications
will be debated according to procedure
rules set out in the council's
Constitution
members of the public can you please
note that you're not permitted to speak
at this meeting unless you've registered
to speak with Democratic services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate and counselors
will be able to make an informed
decision
can I please also remind you to be
respectful of all those attending the
meeting including other members of the
public counselors and officers
members of the public while you can of
course film or take photographs during
the meeting
this should be done without disrupting
the meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please there ask you to raise your
hand clearly in the air if you wish to
take photographs or film this evening
can I ask you then to move to the front
row which is the delegated area for
photography thank you
thank you for that
members your voice will only be captured
on the live stream when your microphone
is switched on
so please remember to switch on your
microphone when you are invited to speak
and switch off again when not speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for for
and then against recommendations and
we're also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing you to abstain from voting
members there is a lengthy addendum for
tonight's meeting with additional
information for each of the three
applications
as everyone had an opportunity to read
these
can I take that as a yes
okay thank you
agenda item one and two we have received
apologies for absence from counselor Mrs
Shaw
and councilor Foster is substituting
councilor Lisa Newport is substituting
for counselor Tracy Knight
non-members attending
we have councilor James Gooding
councilor Julie Gooding councilor Mrs
Christine Mason Council Hoy Council
across
councilor Mrs Newport and a councilor
against him do I have any other
non-members attending
sorry uh councilor James Newport I do
apologize and
and councilor Sharp
and councilor
Nick
Booth sorry mind blank there for a
minute
okay agenda item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of August 2023
are the minutes agree members
thank you
item five to receive Declarations of
interest and can I remind members that
the
Declarations of Interest are there are
three levels of that now which are
disclosable pecuniary interest other
registerable interest non-regitable
interest
do I have any
uh Declarations of Interest
Council Stanley
um
so that is another registerable
okay
foreign
Town Council but I don't see anything
pertaining to radio Town Council on any
item now okay thank you very much for
that
any other
okay thank you
so we move on to agenda item six land
opposite 92 to 102 Windermere Avenue
holbridge members there is additional
information relating this application
set out in the addendum
and um
Katie Rogers will present the report
please thank you
thank you
members this apple Edition relates to
the site
plan on screen
and that's down this boundary here to
the West the southern boundary here the
eastern boundary here and the northern
boundary of sea is adjacent to
Windermere Avenue
[Music]
so planning permission for residential
development of the site was approved in
2022 the plan on screen is the approved
site layout plan members will note a
Terrace of properties and two
semi-detached pairs in the southern part
of the site and a flatted block and two
semi-detached pairs in the northern part
of the site
one vehicle of access was approved in
centrally positioned off Windermere
Avenue parking spaces were approved in
this location here immediately west of
the access
and immediately opposite the
semi-detached pairs in the northern part
of the site there were some additional
parking spaces here
this application before members is a
section 73 variation of condition
application
it has been submitted as a result of it
transpiring that the two oak trees
subject to tree preservation order
this is one here
and one here
were shown outside the red line boundary
in the original application as you can
see on the plan on screen here
when in fact they are correctly within
the red line these trees are labeled T2
and T3
okay so the image on screen now shows a
comparison of an extract of the approved
site layout plan the plan that was just
previously on the screen on the left
hand side here
and members will note the plotting of
the trees just outside the red line
boundary
T2 and T3 are correctly plotted now just
falling within the Red Bank within the
red line boundary on the plan on the
right hand side which is the proposed
layout plan
the original planning consent was
subject to a number of planning
conditions and condition 10 required
tree protection measures and a method of
construction within the root protection
areas of T2 and T3
um
to be undertaken in a in in accordance
with an agricultural method statement
that had been based on incorrect
plotting of the trees so these were the
trees plotted incorrectly there was an
arbor cultural method statement
to control works within the root
protection of those trees but they were
that information was based on the
inaccurate plotting
as a result the developer could not
comply with the original condition 10.
this application has therefore been
submitted to very condition 10 to
require tree protection and method for
working in the root protection areas to
be in accordance with an updated
agricultural method statement which is
now based on the accurate plotting of
these trees
the revised agricultural method
statement includes three tree protection
plans which require pre-protective
fencing to be installed in different
positions as the development progresses
on site
So the plan on screen now is tree
protection plan one and this shows the
tree protection fencing in the in the
position shown by the dashed red line
that's just here if you can see where
that light pen is
this fencing must remain in this
position on site until such a time as
groundworks within the route protection
areas of these two trees either T2 or T3
commences at which point the tree
protection fencing must be moved to the
position shown by the dash red line on
tree protection plan 2. which is this
plan here so you can see now the red
line the dashed red line now just
um follows the sort of Northern edge of
these parking bays and it's just um
closer to the the trunks of those trees
tree Protection Plan Three
shows the fencing in the same position
so this is the third plan again this
tree protection follows this Dash Red
Line
and this is the same as plan two and
this must be retained and in this
position until the development is
complete on site
this plan also indicates the areas
within the route protection area where
different methods of working will be
used to construct the different hard
surfaces
so the parking spaces are in this kind
of lighter beige color they're closest
um to the trees and they're going to be
required to use a low level excavation
method and there'll be a shingle surface
to form the surface of that area
the driveway this is this sort of Darker
beige just south of the parking spaces
within the root protection area will be
formed using a slightly different method
allowing for slightly deeper excavation
than finish with block Paving
the agricultural method statement
details the method for construction of
the two different hard surfaces within
the root protection areas to ensure that
impacts on the root will be minimized
the council's tree officer is satisfied
with the proposed details and recommends
planning conditions and that will
include Arbor cultural site supervision
of works
in addition to seeking to vary condition
10 the application also seeks to vary
condition 2 which lists approved plans
as some of the approved plans also show
the trees plotted incorrectly
[Music]
so the image on screen shows an extract
of the approved Landscaping plan on the
left hand side here
members will note the incorrect plotting
again of T2 and T3 just north of the red
line
the image on the right hand side is an
extract of the proposed Landscaping plan
which now shows the trees correctly
plotted just falling within the red line
site
the proposed Landscaping remains very
similar to the approved scheme with lawn
provided to enclosed Gardens and forward
of the flooded blocks so that's in this
area here
and tree planting across the site
The Proposal still includes the planting
of a new native hedge along sections of
the eastern boundary here the western
boundary here
and a native Hedgerow would continue to
be planned would be a native Hedgerow
will continue to be delivered along the
entire Northern boundary safe for the
vehicle access in the middle
what the proposed plan does now make
clear is that a section of the existing
Hedgerow along the northern boundary the
section west of the access and down this
little part of the western boundary here
would be retained this is shown in a
slightly different color it's just in
like a gray color and it is annotated on
that plan although illegible at this
this level that you're viewing it
the final plan I've got to show you is
the approved boundary plan so again this
is an extract of that plan and on the
left hand side is the approved boundary
plan and on the right hand side is the
proposed boundary plan again this is
submitted to correct the incorrect
plotting of of the two trees members
will note the proposed boundary
treatments remain very similar to those
approved so on the approved scheme we
had a wall proposed around the sort of
southern part of the site and all the
way up the eastern boundary actually and
forming the rear Garden boundary of
these semi-detached properties in this
in the northern corner and again that
that same Arrangement is proposed here
a post-mail fence with low-level
planting is proposed to a section of the
western boundary in this location here
adjacent to the parking Court
and along the northern boundary as we've
I've already discussed there would be a
native hedge
the recommendation is one of approvals
subject to the planning conditions are
set out in the committee report and on
the addendum
in addition it is also recommended that
versions of conditions 3 and 12 from the
original consent be imposed on the grant
of the section 73 application
finally it is noted that the original
consent was subject to a section 106
legal agreement and the recommendation
of approval is therefore subject to the
applicant entering into a data variation
to tie the new planning permission to
the terms of the original legal
agreement
thank you
thank you Casey
we have one public speaker on this item
and that speaker is Mr Rennie who I'd
like to invite to come and speak you
have five minutes I'll let you know when
we come to one minute before we finish
thank you
okay I'll probably start to give a song
all right thank you very much for the
invitation to come along tonight
um
I read the office's report on your
portal the other day and
um young lady here just touched on the
section 106 agreement
I read through the legal 106 agreement
on there there was mention that
Windemere Avenue would be resurfaced
and I thought constructed
that does not seem to be included in the
documentation provided in the officers
report recently
this uh
resurfacing construction as says in the
legal agreement and in the legal
agreement it states that until the road
is resurfaced to Essex Highway standards
and put path created none other
properties on the site can be occupied
and this is a Nickelodeon arrow that
should be included
and return by the development committee
um I listen with interest to the
boundary treatment
and retention the native Hedgerow
on that there was a mention of retaining
the hairdro on the western side
on the Northern boundary but this didn't
be no mention of retaining the Hedgerow
on the north side of the ditch on the
eastern boundary
and I wonder why
the Hedgerow has been a better
contention for me for the last year
having numerous letters to RDC and uh we
never agreed
um
had the plans being drawn up correctly
in the start the Hedgerow would have
been retained
it's classified of historic nature under
the 1997 Hedgerow rules
and that was laid out by RDC primary
Commission the potential outdated back
to 1873
that has been removed
primarily on the Eastern side and
partially on the western side
had that hedger been retained
is highly likely that this application
has been discussed this evening might
not have even even been erased
because at the moment the parking bays
are in the area where the hedger would
have been retained
and they would provide an adequate route
protection for those oak trees
uh the final point I have to raise as
well is on the apartment blocks
um the apartment block is entitled to
eight parking buyers there are seven on
the southern side and three on the
Northern side
the seventh on the southern side have
two visitors Bays
I would assume before I better to have
all eight for the apartment blocks on
the southern side
and two on the Northern side for
visitors hence avoiding the need to be
to knock down part of the uh
is there to make way for a parkingly
uh I put this in writing but I've had no
response from the planning team on this
at all
which I think is rather surprising
um finally I understand that the
drainage from the attenuation tank has
still not being
satisfactorily proven to Rohit Singh
and that's basically about it so I think
I've probably got half a minute left
you have plenty of time thank you very
much Mr Rennie if you would like to
return to your team thank you very much
thank you for the water
okay
um I'd like to start off by just
clarifying that
um this particular application is one
that is fairly narrow in its
consideration and the uh built out
side of the site has been subject to uh
previous uh planning application and
that has been improved been approved so
there is nothing that we can consider on
that sort of side of things there are
issues that I am aware that Katie will
come back on uh there so as we can
clarify the situation for you including
the ones that you brought out Mr ready I
will I will ask
uh you've had your time I'm sorry thank
you very much but we I've noted the
things that you've asked and I will ask
for clarification
okay so moving on
um the visiting members are there any
visiting members award members who would
like to speak on this application please
no okay so over to members any members
like to speak on this application
councilor Stanley
awesome sorry I didn't see you
indicating now
I wasn't indicating sorry
okay
councilor Stanley I believe he wanted to
say something
yes yes please
first of all
um
the road that's indicated on the board
at the moment between the uh Flats if
you like and the houses
um
the entrance at the moment is at the
side of T3
not T2 or in the middle so the entrance
I don't know whether that's a planning
miss that or whatever but at the
entrance is alongside T3 at the moment
there is a lot of traffic coming going
through there including lorries and
there is nothing no provision
for
protecting the roots of that tree also
T1
overhangs the boundary
there is no protection on that T1
although it is uh
a tree preservation order on all of
those trees there doesn't seem to be any
preservation to the roots of T1 as well
so I'd like that sorted please
um as for the and that's on the main
road that runs through there as for the
plants on the Hedgerow I did discuss
this with our planet officer our will
Evans and I've yet to get a full
description of those plants for the
Hedgerow I've not had anything from him
whatsoever
I was told he was going to bring it to
me but he hasn't done so
um
so I don't know
if that is correct that drawing
um
I don't see it as being correct myself
thank you
okay are there any other members wish to
cancel award
well thank you chairman
um I was actually puzzled because
obviously we don't see uh the s-106
agreements at all and uh the resident
has mentioned the road and was the only
agreement to actually bring that road up
to adoptable standard can I use it on
that section 106. sorry can I stop the
accounts award that is subject to
enforcement uh of the previous
application it's not actually what we're
considering here tonight it's just no
thank you but I just wanted to
understand that that question was
brought up and I I can see nothing
within any documents which refer to the
section 106 in regards to that road so
hence I think it's a very pertinent
question irrespective of
how we're looking at this
thank you okay thank you Council
um I think that's something that maybe
could be answered but I'm not sure if we
can answer it tonight
um Katie is standing in but uh you can
yes okay I'll hand over to Katie thank
you
and so taking those questions in reverse
order so that the last question about
the section 106. it is it is relevant to
the determination of this application
because if members approve this section
73 application tonight a new consent is
granted okay and the development will be
built out under this new consent we have
to make sure that all of the um Clauses
in the original 106 still apply in
exactly the same way and that's why I
mentioned Adida variation so a decision
if members take a decision to approve
this application tonight we won't be
able to issue a decision notice
immediately tomorrow
um or next week because we have to enter
the applicant will have to enter into a
data variation it's essentially just a
short legal document that ensures that
the original 106 is now linked to this
new consent and that does contain a
number of Clauses relating to different
matters one of which is the resurfacing
of a section of Windermere Avenue and
the installation of a um way okay so
That Remains the Same as in the original
um application
thank you so much Sharon
um so just to clarify with Katie
um it would mean I take it having not
seen the section 106 agreement I assume
which I shouldn't assume but it will be
done prior to the first occupation
you confirm that please
[Music]
um yep so the Clause relating to the
resurfacing of a section of Windermere
Avenue and the foot way
um does is required to be done prior to
First occupation on the site and to the
satisfaction of the County Council
Highway Authority
um do you want me to can I carry on an
answer yes please do yeah um so in
relation to the um the trees
um the agricultural method statement
that's been submitted the revised one
that now considers the correct plotting
of T2 which is here and T3
um has been looked at by the council's
agricultural officer who has also
attended the site to to look at what
works have been happening
um and is to their satisfaction there is
no objection raise
um so our tree officer is entirely happy
with the extent to which trees have been
surveyed that would be impacted by the
proposed development and the works that
are proposed within the route protection
areas of those trees so this tree here
is labeled as T2 we have a T3 labeled
here I don't have a T1 that's labeled on
the tree protection plan on the method
statements just bring you to this one
here there is another tree that's
plotted outside the site to the western
boundary and root protection area which
is not extending into the site so we are
satisfied that trees that would be
impacted are subject to TPO have been
properly assessed now
um yes there are trees other trees
outside of the site some of which are
subject to TPO and any Works to them
would be a consideration if they had to
take place but to be subject to a
separate application process so you'd
have to get a consent order to do any
work to trees that are outside the site
if any further Works were necessary
thank you chairman
um I'm
could you
bring back the other drawing on the
where the
that's it that one there on the top of
the is that the North Boundary at the
top I believe it is isn't it
there is there is a roadway if you like
that runs through there are the roads
protected on that roadway not that road
but the one on North
where it loads that's it up there yeah
are they are those routes protected
under this auger
um and the fact that the at the moment
the opening onto the site is
to the
eighth digit West to the west of of the
buildings
not that road that isn't there at the
moment it's down the other side which is
just outside the the
redlined area
is that going to be the entrance or is
that going to be the entrance which
one's going to be the entrance to the
building
plot plus the fact uh chairman from the
first day of commencement it was put in
order that the duration of the of all
construction work therefore will be
put onto the site
and that includes
construction traffic
and I presume that being construction
traffic are the people that are working
on the site should be in the site and
not in Windermere
at this moment in time they are parking
outside of the site
and also the site signs are roughly the
same size as our uh nine balls at the
moment which is stuck to the fence I
would ask that those signs be more
visible for loading and unloading on the
site if that's possible to the uh
offices
thank you thank you Council Sandy I
think that's another issue that we'd
have to take up outside the meeting if
I'm writing someone all I would say is
that um we we the condition 12 on the
original consent required a construction
method statement
um and that um was to do with well
included and the management of the
storage of materials on site and
construction workers vehicles
um the we have agreed details in respect
of that
um and I mentioned that we will be
carrying the recommendation is to carry
over that consent to make sure that we
can enforce the terms of that
construction method statement so it
might be what you're touching upon is an
Enforcement issue but it I don't think
it would be
um relevant to the determination of this
application because we're going to carry
forward that condition 12.
all I'll ask it is that because that the
construction of this permeable mattress
if you like that's going to go there
there will be other construction people
going to there to do that specific job
and therefore with 6.5 on the I addendum
identity
item six where it says seven it says
from the first day of commencement so
that means all materials and
construction traffic
and I believe that to be the people that
are working there should be on site and
that's what I'm asking so yeah we have
agreed details of the construction
method statement which seeks to control
where contractors and workers on the
site will park so that condition is
going to be carried recommendation is
that that condition be carried forward
so that we can continue to enforce that
as is necessary okay thank you
thank you Katie
if I could hand over to our legal
expertise
um
this is a
the only reason this application has
come before the committee again is
essentially because as you can see there
the original plan the one on the left
excluded in error the two big trees that
meant they weren't properly protected
through all the conditions and other
measures which the council had put in
place now that permission it remains and
the developer is entitled to and I
believe is beginning to implement it now
it's
it's a good thing to put it in simple
terms that the count that the applicant
has made this application to regularize
the position by which I mean you can see
on the drawing on the right
including
the two protected trees within the red
line that means they will be protected
through all of the measures which were
previously agreed so it's a slightly
unusual application in that sense it's
it's exactly the same but for the the
measures the plan and and to ensure that
the measures actually protect the two
protect the two TPO trees so it is a
slightly unusual one but that's why it
comes before you again
um and it seems to me the office is
absolutely right that
what is required then is a deed of
variation to the existing section 106
simply to link it to the new application
were you to approve it
thank you
um to answer one of the questions that
Mr Rennie brought as well section 2.41
does list quite comprehensively uh the
plants that have been considered for the
new Hedgerow and uh to my mind that does
seem to have been quite
um
soundly considered there are a number
I'm not going to try and
pronounce the names of a lot of them but
there are up to I think it's 66
herbaceous plants and 574 shrubs so it's
quite considerable and I think that we
can deduce from that that there has been
quite a lot of consideration gone into
the Hedgerow on this so unless anyone
else has got anything that I'd like to
contribute no okay so the recommendation
is to approve the application subject to
the conditions set out on pages 6.3 to
6.10 of the report and subject to the
amended conditions and information
informative set out on pages one to five
of the addendum
okay so members those in favor would you
please
oh sorry I need to have a second app do
I have a second app I'll propose from
the gym
thank you
so all those in favor can I have an
indication please
that is unanimous thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
agenda item seven
land opposite sales yard trenders Avenue
Rayleigh
members there is additional information
relating to this application set out in
the addendum
Katie Fowler will present the officer's
report thank you thank you chairman
the application site is located on
trenders Avenue the site is formed of a
parcel of land edged in red on the plan
here so I just follow that the laser
and in measures of parcel of area of
0.29 hectares drenders Avenue is a
private single Track Road and the site
is located part way up the road and is
opposite to the properties known as Pine
cottage which is here Mill Cottage here
the South barn which is here and then
the properties of Heron Street place
here the properties of Heron stream
Place form the land that was once sales
yard so that's where the application
site has had its historic name from
the site is also nearby to the listed
building of trenders Hall which is just
located northwest of the application
site
to the south of the side of the public
right of wayfoot path which runs along
here
and the site's currently occupied by a
stable block and is enclosed along part
of the Eastern and Southern boundaries
by closed board fence
I'll just take you through some site
photos I'm conscious that some members
did visit the site but just to help
those who did not so this gate Mark
demarcates the entrance into the site
and then you have along the eastern
boundary here that close board fence and
then along the southern boundary here
and this photo just shows the public
right-of-way that runs to the South and
you can see that boundary also
I'll just skip through some photos which
are a little bit repetitive but
um here you can see northward's uptrend
is Avenue and you also have the
properties of pine Cottage and Mill
Cottage here and you also have the kind
of substantial hetero demarcating this
boundary and you can see the softness of
other boundary treatments uptrenders
Avenue
this photo shows the entrance to her and
stream place which was once sales yard
foreign
so this photo is just looking
um to the north of the application site
here we have the boundary of South barn
and then this road where it Forks in
trenders Avenue leads up to Trend as
Hall the listed building this part of
the vegetation is actually outside of
the red line boundary and so the
application site sits behind that
this photo just shows a little bit
better the context of this fork in the
road where the application site is so
you can see the closed board fence just
in the background of that photo
and then this photo is just looking into
the application site so we can see the
stable block which exists at present and
then the bond and Hedgerow that runs
along the western boundary as well
members may recall that the stable block
which exists on the site was tied to a
sexual 106 agreement the section 106
agreement stated that the stable block
was to be removed at such a time as the
land edged in blue so that's this parcel
here
um was no longer available for use of
grazing of horses and therefore the
building at present is unlawful
Disco
sorry literally on them becomes
unavailable for the use of grazing of
horses is the Council of understanding
that the landing blue is no longer
available for the use of Grayson and
horses and so the building at present is
unlawful discussions have taken place
with the planning agent for the scheme
who considers the building to be lawful
the planning agent is of the view that
the building is lawful as the section
106 attempted to govern or restrict the
use of the stable building and connect
with the grazing land as opposed to the
building itself
therefore the assessment set up within
the officer report has considered the
building as being retained if it were
unlawful and as a change of use if it
were lawful
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of land for the stationing
of two pitches for a Roman Egyptian
family
so the site plan here depicts the uh
proposed site we've got the red line
here demarcating that site and we can
see where the vegetation Falls outside
of that red line
so we have the darker blue rectangles
here and here which show the mobile
homes and then the lighter blue here as
the touring Caravans so the site would
be made up of two mobile homes and two
touring Caravans the existing stable
rock is proposed to be retained as a
date room
foreign
the application site is located within
the Greenbelt where restrictive policies
apply
the national planning policy for
traveler sites sets out that traveler
sites in the Greenville are
inappropriate development which is
harmful by definition
in addition The Proposal would have an
impact on the openness of the green belt
in terms of the proposal's contribution
towards the purpose of Greenbelt Land
the development would constitute urban
sprawl and encroachment The Proposal
would therefore be considered to have a
greater impact on openness and would
fail to meet the aims and purposes of
allocating them within the green belt
any harm to the green belt is attributed
substantial weight which must be clearly
outweighed by various special
circumstances
the very special circumstances of the
application have been set out within the
officer report these include the
existing lack of local provision the
lack of alternative accommodation and
the personal circumstances of the
applicant in particular the best
interest of the child are a primary
consideration in this application as the
site would accommodate children under 16
and where permission refused the family
would be forced to live on the side of
the road
although not necessarily a determinative
issue no other consideration must be
considered to be more important or given
more weight the best interest of the
child must be at the Forefront of
decision makers Minds when they are
exercising all plan and judgment
involved in this case
it is considered that there are a number
of matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of recent
appeal decisions
in respect of the day room the office
report has set out whether the building
is considered to be lawful or unlawful
that their day room would be acceptable
in connection with the proposed use
if unlawful there are very special
circumstances which exist to outweigh
the harm to the green belt and if law
for the change of use would be considers
are considered as appropriate
development within the Greenville
the cumulative way to the other
considerations are considered to clearly
outweigh the substantial harm in the
Greenville
whilst the development would not be
typical for the character of trenders
Avenue The Proposal would must not be
discriminated against because the homes
of this ethnic group do not look like
those of the settled communities
conditions have been imposed of guiding
the Landscaping on site with the
intention to better integrate in the
development within the street scene
further the price development not be
considered to impact upon the setting of
the nearby listed building
a number of comments have been received
regarding the impact on nearby
Residential Properties it's considered
that there would be sufficient
separation with these properties so that
the proposed development would not have
an overbearing overshadowing or
overlooking impact that would be
unreasonable
the material considerations pertaining
to the impact on residential amenity
have been laid out within the officer
report and found to be acceptable
the proposed development is considered
to provide sufficient access and parking
the number of vehicles associated with
the pros use would be limited and
therefore would not be caused would not
be considered to cause demonstratable
harm upon trenders Avenue
although no specific details of federal
drainage have been submitted a condition
has been recommended requiring these
details
there are a number of trees around the
perimeter of the application site how
the proposed film would not be within
the root protection area of any of these
finally the application site would not
be considered to exhibit any Habitat to
protected species and therefore the
proposal would not have an impact upon
ecology
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
condition set up within the officer
report and those on the addendum
thank you Casey
we have three public speakers on this
item the first I would like to call to
the microphone is councilor Alistair
Matthews
are you speaking on behalf of Rory
Parish Council councilor Matthews you
have five minutes to speak I will give
you a one minute warning when you come
to the end thank you
come on
and speaking on behalf of the Roar of
Parish Council on residents and oppose
this application
the amount of Travelers sites official
and unofficial in and around Royalton
Rayleigh is disproportionate to the rest
of the district
this can be clearly evidence this should
not be a reason to approve further
development but a reason to decline to
ensure that in line with planning policy
for travelers sites but these sites do
not dominate this settled community
if the council were to make the site on
Chelmsford road on the a1245 an official
site although contrary to the parish
council's objections in previous
occasions this would meet the council's
target this site has been there for over
10 years although there are issues with
the site it has special permission to
remain and tell an official site is
established
government planning policy for travelers
states that unmet need is unlikely to
clearly outweigh harm to the green belt
and any other harm so as to establish
very special circumstances
therefore the fact that there is
currently an unmet need for travel sites
should not be given the weight it has
been given in the officer's report
there is also a duty to cooperate with
others just districts it has been
highlighted that there are pictures
available in Wickford in addition Essex
County Council run 12 sites and the
applicant could equally apply for a
pitch on one of these rather than allow
more harm to the green belt
it should also be noted that the
applicant does currently have a place to
live and therefore there is no immediate
need to conform as conformed confirmed
in addendum 2 from the officer
policy also states that planning should
not put undue pressure on local
infrastructure there is already pressure
with the new housing development of
rural flame which means that local
doctors have no space for new patients
and there are no school vacancies in
local schools
in contrast there are School places at
craze Hill school which has recently had
a very positive ofsted report that I
understand is a school that caters very
well for travelers and it is closer to
the applicant's current address than
Trends Avenue
policy dm1 planning must ensure that
safe and suitable access to the site can
be achieved for all users
this is still a case where it is a
private road
the committee members who visited will
have seen how narrow the road is it is
clearly inappropriate for touring
Caravans and larger Vehicles additional
traffic will increase risk
there are many children
and visiting children plus dog walkers
and visitors to Stables who walk and
cycle on trenders Avenue
residents have asked for a risk
assessment this has not been responded
to
additional traffic and the moment of
Caravans will impact on immunity for
those residents whose properties front
onto
trenders Avenue
um
due to the addendum today from the
officer there's a couple of points there
I would from addendum at 0.7
there are not a number of sites on
trenders Avenue with mobile homes other
than unlawful ones
knowing the address provided on the land
registry is not evidence of gypsy status
I agree with the additional conditions
proposed if planning is approved and
would recommend further conditions
I agree with the additional conditions
requested by residents restricting
commercial activity in the presence of
absence of any information by the
applicant
it is essential and fundamental that the
foul drainage system be installed and
working before occupancy is otherwise
there will be a risk of foul drainage
will contaminate the nearby Watercourse
and be an environmental risk
this is particularly important as the
drawing still fails to show the proposed
day room with showers toilets and
kitchens is connected to the water
treatment system
the day run should conform to the
government guidelines under Section 7
Paris 17-26 which sets out the standard
by which the building should conform
particularly with Energy Efficiency the
internal air and Facilities
the planning application process relies
on people acting in good faith
a potential offense has been committed
by the applicant under Section 65
bracket 6 of the Town and Country
planning act 1990 as the applicant
knowingly provided incorrect information
about the ownership of the land in the
original planning application
the applicant had earned the site for
two years it's not a slight error
even if the committee do not consider
this material to planning it is
misleading and goes to integrity and is
a reason residents have asked for
sufficient evidence about drawing too
close now please
residents have expressed to me how
concerned they are that they are asked
to accept what is presented on face
value without verification and I would
ask committee members to ensure that
they are satisfied with the evidence in
this case for example personal
circumstances why the applicant must
reside on Trends Avenue Gypsy status
occupation academics can be a reason to
refuse thank you for your divisions
thank you
sorry we have the second speaker who is
uh Mr Green who's speaking on behalf of
the applicants Mr Green please take your
place in the microphone you have five
minutes to speak I'll give you one more
one minute uh notice when we come
towards the end thank you
thank you chair thank you committee good
evening I am Nathaniel Green from Green
planning studio and I'm speaking on
behalf of our client Thomas Scott in
support of this application
committee is here to decide the matter
on planning issues only and this
application is recommended for approval
subject conditions the application for a
change of use of land and building for
the stationing of Caravans for
residential purposes
and first can I um
thank the officer for a very
comprehensive addendum which has been
very very useful
it is accepted that the development in
the metropolitan Greenbelt is an
appropriate the fact that the council's
officers have recommended approval shows
that officers have accepted that there
are very special circumstances to
overcome this
due to the green belt boundary being
tightly drawn around existing
settlements it is unlikely that such
development would be able to be put upon
anything other than Greenbelt Land
Azure officers report explains in great
detail from paragraph 2.24 to 2.35 there
is a fundamental need in the district
that other than windfall sites such as
these will not be met in the foreseeable
future
District Council accepts there is a
requirement for at least 10 pitches and
this is likely to be an underestimate
our client and his family are accepted
as having Gypsy status by the council it
is also accepted by the council that
their present living arrangements
involve doubling up with other members
of the extended family
due to the site that they were on being
closed down by the owner as a result the
sites they are forced to live on are in
breach of their own planning conditions
also noted in your report at 2.34 it is
not for the applicant to establish
whether they are available sites but
from the council
the council cannot demonstrate five
years land supply of deliverable Gypsy
sites and this coupled with the lack of
formal policy regarding windfall sites
such as this one constitutes a failure
of policy that also counts heavily in
favor of the application
this application therefore demonstrates
more than one very special circumstance
that is required to outweigh the harm to
the green belt
allowing this application will allow the
family to have a stable base for their
poor children that will allow them to
have an education it will also allow the
applicant's mother who has health issues
to have access to local Health
Facilities whereas at present she has to
travel two hours for medical care
and can I just reiterate that the rights
of the child in that regard are
Paramount
site lies and Countryside that is well
screened on three sides by existing
vegetation the proposed plan shows that
further planting of trees and hedges
will be implemented primarily to the
north and west
the nearest occupied dwelling is 38
meters away to the east across trenders
Avenue and as all structures will be
single story there will be no
overlooking
there is considered to be no impact upon
highways and it will also have little
ecological impact upon the immediate
area however an ecological enhancement
condition will be accepted
further to paragraph 2.57 I can confirm
that the indicative floor plans have
been supplied to show the conversion of
the stable block into a day room of a
suitable size for two pitches
and I can also confirm that our client
is happy with the revised plan as
recently submitted and as requested by
the council
there have been discussions as to
whether the stable block is lawful or
not and whether it constitutes a new
building or change of use
it has also been suggested that a
description of the development be
amended to refer to the retention of the
building
this suggested change the description
the development was not agreed on the
basis that the building has planning
permission the retention is of something
is not an active development but with
the only the other option of being the
material change of use in the building
the building exists and was erected with
the benefit of planning permission zero
two double zero two three five uh the
2002 planning permission did not impose
any conditions sorry
thank you
um
anyway the section 106 agreement sits
alongside the planning permission for
the building and its attempts to govern
or restrict the use of the State
Building in connection with the use of
an area of land for the grazing of
horses should the council Grant planning
permission for the change of use of the
building which would be used to
ancillary to the use of the of the land
for the stationing of Caravans and then
the section 106 agreement was seized to
have any practical or meaningful effects
um the recommendation now comes with 12
conditions and our happy is our client
is happy to comply with them including
the revisions in the addendum
and on that basis I urge you to approve
the application thank you thank you Mr
Green
the third speaker is Miss costan who is
speaking on behalf of residents
objecting to the application disgusting
please take your place at the microphone
you have five minutes and with everyone
else I will let you know when we come to
one minute towards it thank you
thank you good evening my name is Terry
costine I'm a resident of trendis Avenue
and I'm the fourth generation of my
family to live there I'm speaking on
behalf of 25 residents who oppose this
application
planning policy for traveler sites 2015
makes clear that planning in the
Greenbelt is inappropriate and harmful
it is only a very special circumstances
clearly outweigh the harm to the green
belt and any other harm that permissions
should be granted it further states that
subject to the best interests of the
child personal circumstances an unmet
need are unlikely to clearly outweigh
harm to the green belt and any other
harm so as to establish very special
circumstances
this sentence is repeated twice in the
guidance at 16 and under age decision
making therefore set in a very high bar
we do not believe the applicant is
demonstrated or evidence to the council
very special circumstances to a degree
that would clearly outweigh harm to the
green belt and other harm
a site visit would have demonstrated
both the close proximity to the settled
community and The prominent position on
trenders Avenue this is in stark
contrast to other similar planning
applications in the area where sites are
set back from the road or on side roads
there are a cluster of 13 houses around
the proposed site some as close as six
meters some directly face the site and
the proposed development would therefore
significantly significantly impact
immunity and the overall character and
cause harm to the area the planning
officer already the already already
acknowledges that Caravans are not in
keeping with the houses on tremendous
Avenue and noise impact will be
significant paragraph 13 of the mppts
states that planning authorities should
promote peaceful and integrated
coexistence between the site and local
community
the developments of both Trend as Muse
and hair and stream plays were passed
specifically to improve the character
and Immunity of the area this was
determined to be the very special
circumstance in that case passing
planning in this case would therefore
completely undermine these previous
decisions
the planning policy for travelers says
that any planning should respect the
settled community and for local planning
authorities to have due regard to the
protection of local amenity and local
environment the dm1 policy carries
significant weight the objectives
include to ensure that new developments
respect and make a positive contribution
towards the built environment and should
promote visual immunity the fence that
was erected by the applicant in 2021
already shows disregard for visual
immunity in the area
we believe that personal circumstances
have been given too great away in this
case policy states that personal
circumstances are unlikely to clearly
outweigh harm to the green belt we've
been told of no specific reasons why
personal circumstances mean the
applicant needs to live on this site
with its identified arm to the green
belt with regard to schools there is no
requirement to have a permanent
residence to access education indeed the
education system makes special statutory
provision for travelers and even allows
registration at more than one school
with regard to Health Care a permanent
resident is is not required to access
health care and this is a matter for
Health Service Administration not
special circumstances under the planning
law we've asked for guidance for
evidence on the Gypsy status
if the applicant is dependent on this as
a material consideration to gain
planning in Greenbelt then surely it is
for them to provide this evidence and
for the office to be satisfied with the
evidence in the legal commentary we've
provided it states that it is not
sufficient for a planning officer to
write subjects to the lack of evidence
to the contrary but this is exactly
what's happened in this case and no
evidence of status has been provided in
the absence of gypsy status provision
should be refused we understand it is
not possible to insist that the
applicant details of occupation even
though this could have a further
detrimental impact on amenity we
therefore support the request for
further conditions especially no
commercial activity or storage of plant
and Machinery on the site however we
would like to make clear that we oppose
this development and do not believe the
special circumstances outweigh the harm
to the green belt and other harm
relating to proximity prominence and
access
thank you for taking the time to
consider our arguments thank you
before we go to members on this there
are a couple of things that I want to
say on this um
first of all I want to make it clear
that in our adjudication of this
application we can only refer to
planning law and planning policy this
committee is restricted to that so with
that being clear
the second thing is that I had a number
of communications from counselors today
um asking about the particular situation
that we have which has been mentioned
with regards to the private confidential
information
uh that was
judged by the officers and members were
concerned that we as a committee did not
have access to that I had a meeting with
our legal representative before the
meeting and a conversation with officer
Anna legal legal representation and to
that end I'd like to actually pass the
microphone over to Giles to explain the
situation on that so we can be clear
thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman um
you all know you're very familiar with
the ppts that um personal circumstances
of the applicant are something which you
are required to take
into account when making a decision
of this sort
now the reason in this case that
the personal circumstances haven't been
disclosed to you
is because the applicant asked that they
weren't
now I understand and absolutely
obviously could confirm this is right I
understand that the officer has
since given your concerns about not
having seen this information the
applicant or certainly applicant agent
has agreed that some of that information
may be made available is that is that
correct Casey
okay
now
it seems to me
that
either you as a committee could just
accept the word of your officer I'm sure
you don't doubt
what she what she says when she
summarizes information but I can also
see that is it you the members are
actually making the decision
you ought to be
told about the relevant personal
circumstances in this case
and given that
the agent has agreed that that should be
allowed
I suggest that there is a distinction in
the information
some of it
some of the personal circumstances are
clearly relevant to the decision which
you have to make and it seems to me that
that ought to be disclosed to the
committee and I could do that in a
minute if if people are happy with that
there is some other information in there
which is more if you like more personal
is essentially uh detailed Health Care
information
which it seems to me isn't
relevant
necessarily to your decision and
respecting the wishes of the applicants
I don't propose to say anything about
that
so it's Joe if you're happy with that
course of action
yeah I would suggest then that maybe we
adjourn for five minutes for you to
address the committee or are you happy
to do it in Open Session
well I can ask for legal point of view
on this first please I will come back to
members yeah I mean I think the point
I'm making is that I think it's right
that the committee themselves obviously
know this information
um now
weather the applicant would wish for
members of the public not
to be made aware of that information uh
it is another matter and it may be that
that was something we could
discuss if we do have a short
adjournment
okay thank you for the advice members on
that particular aspect nothing else just
on that aspect can I have any uh
comments I believe Council Lawson you
were first
thank you chairman I don't see why we
can't deal with this in exactly the same
we do with four counts we'll have a a
private recess while we discuss this
freely with legal and then we can come
back and discuss the case that's my
opinion
okay Council Lefty
I agree with that chairman I must
suggest that the committee leave and go
to the room as you enter the building on
the left instead of trying to get
everybody out this room
yeah I think that's a useful
recommendation thank you so in that case
I will adjourn the meeting sorry Chad
before I do that I just I I will need to
speak to the agent so if people see me
talking to him just to make sure just to
be clear about what it is that he's
anxious isn't if anything disclosed to
the members of the commission yeah I'm
happy with that accounts for Stanley
yeah I don't see any reason why the
legal can't go into the room and discuss
that with them and then come back and
let us know then we can do exactly what
we need to do sounds reasonable
um is the applicant happy with that yep
okay uh I'll adjourn the meeting then
I thought sorry
I think the proposal is that the
applicant and our legal representative
go there first
okay let's do it this way the legal
representative and the applicant will go
to the coffee area behind the screens to
my right and have a conversation members
we will adjourn to the room in the front
of the building and we will come back as
soon as we have uh that information
thank you